[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens formidable et je
pense que son bien par rapport à
d'autres grandes villes
quels ils n'ignorent au pays ou groupe à
madrid
votre elle en pense quoi mon frère
qu'elle ferait carita nuit et dale
miller veut fermer ou dit qu'est ce
qu'il y oppose eu mon frère pourquoi mon
frère
la turquie est pas là non c'est mon
frère qui sait encore comment ça va mon
frère ça tombe à la moustache
je trouve un rer un bus surtout
n'utilisez a bien trop quand je veux
pour aller où je et votre à elle en
pense quoi
mon frère a séduit mon frère peut-être
que quelque chose bon ok transports en
commun parisiens il n'en pense pas grand
chose à [ __ ]
ok la couture pas bien fait là j'ai vécu
un peu partout dans le monde
l'amérique du sud en amérique du nord
l asie du sud est et tout sa fin dans
tous ces pays là mais je trouve que
c'est pas mal non et votre elle en pense
quoi
mon autre frère c'est une plaisanterie
ça roule ah si le truc si l'on pense
quand votre truc non truc je suis tout
de suite pensé rien moi je me suis fait
piéger ses cavic ovale je sais pas
janssen devant lui et sur les transports
en commun c'est ça c'est la connerie
j'avais un bon jour à ba ba après c'est
totalement
[Musique]